[Music]
you know what let's just forget about
the haters and focus on the love for
Roseann the Connors crushed it with more
than 18 million people tuning in for the
premiere which by the way is bananas no
wonder the cast is taking a victory lap
today I'm just over the moon at the
support of the Roseanne family the
Connors are back and we're all really
happy yeah I heard that you know the
Roseanne premier did really well we are
so grateful to the fans I mean it's just
unbelievable hey what do you think of
the huge ratings on Roseanne guy last
night after a two-decade hiatus the cast
is thrilled about the show's epic
ratings Roseanne told GMA the president
called to congratulate her they said
hold please for the President of the
United States of America and you know
it's about the most exciting thing ever
thank you for making America great again
Roseanne's getting credit for injecting
a dose of comedy into current events and
you might be surprised to learn what
sparked the revival this all started
when John and you did the skit on the
talk I'm a talk show host so what
happened in the steps after that to have
a full-blown breather you know I'd been
thinking about doing something and then
when John said he'd do it I just I
didn't think that everybody would do it
like two weeks later we had a deal with
ABC and yeah I was head spinning the
cast is shot nine episodes news about a
second season is expected any day can we
already bank on like a season 3 season 4
it would be nice but yeah they you're
real positive to tell me anything or
else I'd go out and buy a couple of cars
a speedboat stuff I don't need
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]